Hallo, guten Tag.
Polat ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Eskender erst im Tätig.
Und würde gerne Ihnen ein Anamnese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, haupt doch, dass ich mir Hilfe bekommen will.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Okay, bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Messerien sprechen, werde ich zuerst Ihre persönlichen Daten erfahren.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Franke.
Petra Franke. Ich will Sie bitte Ihren Nachname buchstabieren.
Ja, F-R-A-N-K-I.
I, ups, ich.
I am Ende.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Franke?
Ich bin 40 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.07.82.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 Kilo wiegen.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
1,78 m.
Okay, Frau Franke.
Was für eine Beschwerden haben Sie? Wie kann ich für Sie helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit heute, also ja, eigentlich hatte ich das gestern nach dem Mittagessen,
hat das angefangen, da, dass ich, dass ich solche, solche Schmerzen hatte.
Und zwar im Bauch.
Und das hat ausgestrahlt, sitz in den Rücken und in die Seiten rein.
Und ich habe dann gedacht, oh, was ist denn jetzt los?
Also, ganz, ganz heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Und ja, mir ist auch, mir ist auch schlecht gewesen.
Und das waren richtig, richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Und ich habe dann wohl mal 800 Milligramm Igofrophäen genommen.
Dann ist es ein klein wenig besser gewesen.
Aber insgesamt geht es mir also gar nicht gut.
Und mir ist so schlecht.
Und heute Morgen musste ich mich dann auch übergeben.
Dann habe ich gedacht, jetzt gehe ich doch ins Krankenhaus.
Sie haben gut geschmeckt, so umzugehen.
Diese Bauchschmerzen, haben diese Bauchschmerzen plötzlich angefangen
oder eher langsam?
Also eher plötzlich nach dem Essen.
Und dann ist es immer schlimmer geworden.
Mhm, okay.
Ähm, wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Mittig, ob er war, oder links- und rechts-seitig?
Also, wenn ich mir das überlege, dann gehen die rundherum.
Also, ziemlich weit oben.
Ja, wie gut ist es von einem?
Einmal im ganzen Kreis rum.
Wie gut ist es von einem, ich meine sie.
Ja, also kann man das beschreiben.
Mhm.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder gehen sie wieder links?
Nein, die sind eigentlich immer schlimmer geworden.
Und sie sind nicht weggegangen.
Ich bin ein bisschen weniger durch das Ibuprofen,
aber als es dann, ne, dann hat es auch wieder angefangen.
Und heute Nacht habe ich fast nicht geschlafen,
weil ich eben auch solche Schmerzen hatte.
Und zudem habe ich in der Nacht auch noch so bespitzt,
da musste ich mir zwischendurch noch wieder
ein frisches Nachtenten anziehen
und mir ein Handtuch ins Bett legen,
weil das alles nachts geschwitzt war.
Und ja, also das ist irgendwie gar nicht gut.
Frau Franke, können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend, bräunend?
Ach, wie kann man Schmerzen beschreiben?
Das ist schwierig.
Würde die als dumpf, aber dumpf schneiden vielleicht,
so beschreiben?
Dumfe Schmerzen.
Ja, aber auch schneiden.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzkawa,
wobei ein sehr leichte Schmerz
und zehn starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Da würde ich sagen, die sind bei acht, ne?
Die haben richtig höchstgier.
Ja, Sie haben sehr starke Schmerzen.
Könnten Sie bitte bis Ende des Geschenkpräs diese Schmerzen aushalten?
Ja, ich hatte ja auch noch mal irgendwo hin genommen.
Ich denke mal, dass ich das schon aushalten kann.
Okay, super.
Frau Franke, hat es sich früher schon einmal
diese ähnliche Beschwerden?
Also, wenn ich so überlege,
vor vier Tagen, da hatte ich auch schon mal,
da hatte ich so Pfannekuchen gegessen,
auch schön mit viel Öl gebraten.
Und da ist es mir auch schon nicht gut gegangen.
Aber das ist dann wieder besser geworden.
Aber so blustarkig schmerzen wie jetzt,
das habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Sie haben nur vor vier Tagen einmal gehabt.
Ja, sonst früher, kenne ich das nicht.
Nein.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie sich übergeben
oder übergeben mussten.
Das war heute Morgen.
Nur heute Morgen.
Heute Morgen musste ich einmal, ja, genau.
Ja, wie sah das Erbruch aus?
Ja, das war so gelblicher Schleim.
Ja.
Hatten Sie Fieber
oder haben Sie Fieber oder Stückholz?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen.
Aber auf aller Fälle habe ich wahnsinnig geschwitzt in der Nacht.
Vielleicht habe ich tatsächlich Fieber, das kann ja auch sein.
Mhm.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, also, ganz bisschen habe ich in letzter Zeit abgenommen.
Hat mich schon gefreut, dass ich ein Kilo weniger hatte.
Aber das ist vielleicht so.
Weniger als ein Kilo.
Ein Kilo ist weniger gewesen.
Aber ein Kilo weg oder drauf, das merkt man ja kaum.
Ja, kein Problem.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise gut, aber jetzt natürlich im Augenblick,
woher darf ich gar nicht an Essen denken?
Nicht gut essen können.
Nein, zurzeit natürlich nicht mit diesen Bisswerten,
mit der Übelkeit.
Ja, verstanden.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Zum Beispiel Urin-Verfärbung, oder?
Das ist mir nicht ausgefallen.
Aber so genau habe ich da auch nicht geguckt.
Oder beim Stuhlgang haben Sie etwas Ungereppenscheid.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass ich in den letzten Tagen
extrem Blähungen hatte.
Ja, okay.
Kein Problem mit Stuhlgang und Wasserlassen.
Hab ich nicht verstanden?
Ja, halt nur ein bisschen Blähungen, ne?
Ja, ein bisschen Blähungen.
Sie haben Probleme mit Schlafen, weil wegen Ihren Schmerzen...
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen halt, ne?
Ja.
Weil sie auch so schlecht sind.
Okay.
Frau Franke, waren Sie früher beim anderen Arzt wegen dieser Bissverde?
Nein, nein.
Ich bin zwar regelmäßig in ärztlicher Behandlung,
aber deswegen bin ich nicht zum Arzt gegangen.
Aber jetzt bin ich mir so schlecht,
dass ich gedacht habe, da muss ich gar nicht erst zum Haus abgehen.
Da komme ich gleich hinzugehen.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausschläuser für diese Beschwärten?
Ja, das ist nach dem Essen gekommen.
Und beim ersten Mal, als das noch nicht so schlimm war,
da hatte ich ja Kanneckuchen gegessen.
Und jetzt hatte ich auch ein bisschen pettige Bratkartoffeln.
Ja, das ist echt toll.
Denk mal, dass das vielleicht doch ein bisschen viel pett war,
was ich da hatte.
Verstanden.
Frau Franke, ich würde über Ihre folgische Frage.
Ist Ihnen irgendweils chronische Alkrankungen bekannt?
Wie Bluthoff-Bruck, Diabetes?
Ich weiß, dass ich ein bisschen Bluthoff-Bruck habe.
Und ich habe auch ein bisschen erhöhte Blutschettwerte.
Und was mir wirklich zu schaffen macht,
mit ziemlicher Regelmäßigkeit habe ich so Migräne attacken.
Man geht mir wirklich schlecht.
Und da muss ich eben auch Medikamente lesen.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie Bluthoff-Bruck?
Das ist noch nicht so lange.
Ich bin ja noch nicht so alt.
Aber ja, vielleicht so vier, drei, vier Jahre hat man das festgestellt.
Und da hat man dann eben auch gesehen, dass die Cholesterin-Werte so ein bisschen hoch sind.
Ja, erhöfte Cholesterin-Werte auch seit zwei oder vier Tagen festgestellt.
Ja, vier Jahre.
Ja, das hat man damals gleichzeitig irgendwie bemerkt.
Ja, verstanden.
Und die Migräne damit frage ich mich schon seit der Pubertät drum.
Okay.
Haben Sie regelmäßige Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich nehme das gegen den Blutschhoff-Bruck.
Aber ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, wie das heißt.
Und dann habe ich auch so eine Speziale Tablette, die ich bei Migräne anfällen nehmen soll.
Aber ich habe jetzt tatsächlich die Zettel, weil sie mir so schlecht ging.
Ja, ich habe gar nicht mit, ich kann Ihnen das jetzt nicht sagen.
Dann müssen Sie wegen der Namen von meinem Hausarzt einfach rufen.
Ja, okay.
Oder ich melde mich nach Hause auch bei Ihnen?
Ja, ja, kein Problem.
Ich kann Ihren Hausarzt erfahre, erfahre.
Aber sie kann gerade nicht diese Name erlernen.
Von den Medikamenten? Nein, die weiß ich nicht.
Ja, okay.
Sind Sie früher schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte hier Blindam, so als junge Frau, ich war 18 oder 17, muss das gewesen sein.
Aber sonst keine weitere Operation.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen gegen etwas allergisch bekannt, allergin- bekannt oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, allergisch bin ich eigentlich auch nix.
Sind Sie vollständig ge- in Corona?
Ja, gegen Corona habe ich drei.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Im Ausland? Nein, bin ich nicht gewesen.
Okay.
Was ist der Ferien?
Ja, Frau Franke, haben Sie regelmäßige Periode?
Ja, das funktioniert ganz gut.
Ja, wir suchen Sie regelmäßig beim Frauenarzt?
Ja, natürlich, also zu dieser Krisphorso- und jährlichen Kontrolluntersuchung.
Oh, super.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie schwanger sein könnten?
Nein, also da bin ich mir ganz sicher, dass ich nicht schwanger bin.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Franke, rauchen Sie?
Ja, so eine Schachtel am Tag rauchen Sie schon, ja.
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit ich 20 bin.
So wann ich bin?
Ja, Sie rauchen viel.
Wenn Sie das rauchen und aufhören möchten, können Sie mir melden und kann ich gerne helfen.
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein Angebot. Mal gucken, ja.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also nicht so viel.
Ich trinke wohl abends mal so ein, zwei Flaschen Bier, eins zum Abendbrot und eins dann noch so zum Fernsehgucken oder so.
Und wenn wir es feiern, dann trinke ich natürlich auch mal ein paar mehr Bier.
Oder dann gibt es auch mal ein bisschen hochprozentige Geschichten.
Aber so regelmäßig eigentlich nur die ein, zwei Bier.
Ich möchte noch mal fragen, Sie trinken regelmäßig abends ein oder zwei Flaschen Bier.
Ja, fast regelmäßig zwei Flaschen Bier, kann man sagen.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Oh ja, seit ich erwachsen bin, mit 30 habe ich das angefangen, ja.
Ja, mit 30.
Okay, nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen?
Nee, also mit anderen Sachen habe ich keine Experimente gemacht, nein.
Okay.
Frau Franka, Leben oder Elten?
Ja, meine Eltern leben beide.
Ist in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrer Elterne irgendwer, der chronische Elbfrancungen bekommt?
Meine Eltern sind ganz gesund.
Nee, meine Eltern sind beide ziemlich fit und gesund.
Ein Bruder habe ich, dem geht es nicht so gut.
Der hat eine lieberzehrose.
Leberzehrose.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Laborantin in der Chemieindustrie.
Interessant.
In Chemieindustrie.
Ja, das wäre spannend.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, die leben auch zusammen und die Kinder gehen zur Schule natürlich.
Ja, sind ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund und glücklich, ja.
Frau Franka, treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich fahre schon regelmäßig mit dem Fahrrad in der Gegend herum, wenn ich irgendwas zu erledigen habe.
Und wenn ich mal gute Vorsätze habe, mache ich auch mal ein paar Tage gemastik, aber das hört meistens schnell wieder auf.
Regelmäßig Sport würde ich nicht sagen.
Verstanden.
Ja.
Frau Franka, meineseits habe ich wichtige Frage gestellt. Möchten Sie etwas füllen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich wissen, was man gegen diese Schmerzen machen kann und woher die denn willkommen.
Ja.
Und ja, halt auch, was ich dagegen tun kann, damit das endlich aufhält mit den Schmerzen.
Und wenn das nicht wieder kommt.
Ja, Frau Stefan, Frau Franka.
Jetzt erst mal so erst, wir müssen, werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, dann ein paar diagnostische Maßnahmen durchführen.
Dann kann ich etwas genauer sagen.
Aber nach bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Bauchspeise Drose Entzündung aus.
Meine Bruncherwachter haben wir da machen.
Ja, ich werde Sie Bullut abnehmen, um diese Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Dann werde ich diese Therapie anfangen.
Aber ihr müsst Sie bei uns beleiden.
Ich muss zuerst näher bleiben?
Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Ich freue mich natürlich aufs Bett, aber die Kinder werden natürlich gucken, wenn die Mutter nicht nach Hause kommt.
Da muss ich mal nachher gleich beim Mann anrufen, dass der Kinder von der Schule abholt.
Ja, Ihre Gesundheit ist sehr wichtig.
Deswegen, Sie müssten ins Krankenhaus bleiben, um weitere Untersuchungslöschen zu führen.
Ich würde Sie gerne auf den Platz nehmen und dann rufe ich auf.
Danke schön.
Ich habe noch eine Kollegin fragen, ich habe keine Fragen.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Sie arbeiten in Chemie.
Ist Ihre Arbeit mit 15-Ten gesundheitlichem Gefahren verbunden?
Ach so, nein, wir haben ein ganz gutes Sicherheitssystem und unser Laborleiter sagt, also eigentlich sind wir ganz sicher.
Danke.
Weitergehen, aber?
Okay, okay, gut.
Guten Abend Frau Oberstein, ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen, die ich vorstellen möchte.
Hab ich bereit dafür?
Ja natürlich klar.
Die Patientin heißt Petra Franke, sie ist ab 18, 17, so weit um 80 gewohnt, sie ist 80 kg und 1,73 m groß.
Die 40-jährige Patientin stellte sich bei uns seit gestern Abend bestehend um dunkle Bauchschmerzen
in Ausstrahlung mit den Rücken.
Mit Ausstrahlung in den Rücken, oder?
Ja in den Rücken.
Die Schmerzen hätten plötzlich angefangen und seien postprandial aufgezwitten.
Die Schmerzen hätten sich im Verlauf der Zeit versteckt auf einer Schmerzkala legen bei 8.
Die Patientin berichtete, dass gegen diese Schmerzen einmal Ibuprofen eingenommen.
Das hat ihnen ein bisschen geholfen.
Mhm.
Die Patientin gab anders vor 4 Tagen auch ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt habe.
Diese Beschwerden hätten postprandial nach dem fertigen Essen aufgezwitten.
Moment, Moment.
Die Beschwerden sind nach dem Essen aufgetreten.
Das ist aufgetretenes Bewegungswert.
Ja.
Außerdem klackte die Patientin über Blähungen, Nachschweiß, Neusea und Emesis und Indomia.
Heute Morgen habe die Patientin einmal Erbruch.
Das Erbruch sei geltlich.
Als Vorerkrankungen nannte die Patientin eine arterielle Hypertonie, Hypercholesterolemi und Migraine.
Die Patientin nimmt regelmäßig ein paar Medikamente ein, aber sie konnte sich nicht daran erneuern.
An dem Namen des Medikamentes.
An dem Namen der Medikamente, okay.
Mit Erneuern.
Sie haben keine Medikamente dabei.
Sie wurde mit 18 Lebensjahre appendokteniert.
Bei ihnen ist kein Allergin Beckham.
Bei ihr ist keine Allergin Beckham.
Ja, stimmt.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
In der genecologischen Anomnease berichtete die Patientin, dass sie regelmäßige Periode haben.
Bei ihren Frauen, als regelmäßig besucht.
Die Patientin oder Frau Franke,
seit 20 Jahren ein Schachtel pro Tag,
das 20-Park-Ufjahr erneut errichtet.
Sie trinken abends seit 10 Jahren ein oder zwei Flasche Bier.
Aber am Feier, am Feiertag, mehr trinken.
Die sonstigen Drogen wurden verneint.
Ihre Mutter und ihr Vater haben keine chronische Erkrankungen.
Aber ihr Bruder leidet an Leberstilosen.
Sie ist Laborentin von Beruf in einer Chemieindustrie.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie lebt mit ihrer Familie zusammen.
Sie treibt nicht regelmäßig Sport.
Diese anomnistische Angabe spricht für akute Pankreatitis.
Als differenzial diagnostisch könnte es Hepatitis und Colilitiasis.
Um die Verdachdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich folgende diagnostische Massnahme durchführen.
Zuerst werde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Beim Palpitations und Palpitations,
versuche ich, zu bemerken Abwehrspannungen oder Darngeräusche.
Das ist eine genaue Lokalisation der Schmerzen.
Ich würde die Sonografie durchführen.
Ich werde die Sonografie durchführen.
Ich werde eine Antiliose durchführen.
Sie wird relativ angelegt.
Ich werde auch durchführen.
Ich werde die Sonografie durchführen.
Ich denke, das war sehr gut heute Abend.
Wenn irgendetwas Sprachliches war, habe ich eigentlich immer gleich gesagt.
Ich bin immer gleich aufs Fischen gegangen.
Aber jetzt versuchte ich besser so werden.
Ja, das ist gut gelaufen.
Die Präsentation war relativ einwandfrei.
Ich glaube, Sie können jetzt berichten.
Dann lassen Sie uns heute wieder bewenken.
Herr Gündig, wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder.
Wir machen jetzt Feierabend.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen ein gutes und erholsames Wochenende.